only a few weeks after black ops 3
launched the call of duty advanced
warfare developer is already getting
amped for their next game sledgehammer
games co-founder and chief creative
officer Glenn Schofield is so [ __ ]
excited for the developers next game
writing on Twitter he didn't give away
any specifics about what the game might
be but something in the call of duty
spaces expected given the studio's
history and status he posted on Twitter
we're designing a new game so in design
mode I do art that's how I think
probably weird but it's my way of
concentrating Schofield added can't talk
about the game but we listened and i'm
so [ __ ] stoked about this one
sledgehammers latest game was 2014's
call of duty advanced warfare the studio
based in foster city california is owned
by activision the studio co-developed
call of duty modern warfare 3 with
Infinity Ward in the wake of the fallout
surrounding the exit of the studios
founders and many staff before
sledgehammer launched into modern
warfare 3 the team was working on a
third person call of duty game that took
place in the vietnam war in Cambodia
sledgehammers other founders Michael
condry previously said he would like to
return to that game someday the call of
duty series is now on three year three
studio development cycle with Trey arcs
call of duty black ops 3 launched this
year in advanced warfare coming up last
year that would mean Infinity Ward's
next game is likely the candidate for
2016 sledgehammers would presumably
follow in 2017 if the franchise's
previous development schedule holds now
I don't know if I'm sold on a third
person call of duty game but I'd love to
see one that takes place during the
Vietnam War for more on call of duty
black ops 3 stay tuned to gamespot